all right let's go to our next caller
from the 4:02 area code caller from 402
we are up against the break here in a
couple minutes so please introduce
yourself and tell us what's on your mind
today hi um my name is chase I'm
actually from Minnesota uh it just blows
my mind I actually got you to take my
call here you're on what so what's on
your mind today oh um well I mean I just
got done watching a little secular talk
bit and it talked about how the White
House came out with the statement
talking about how there's like signs
that there's preparations for Syria to
start like making more chemical weapons
for another attack and I wasn't
necessarily agreeing with the narrative
the last time that came around and it
kind of felt a little false flag II to
me and so it's just definitely putting
me on the weary side with them coming
out with another statement like this and
so I kind of just wanted to get your
opinion on cuz yeah productive there's a
couple possibilities here we did talk
about that with a number of shows have
been talking about that because it is so
weird there's a couple possibilities--
because the White House came out and
said hey you know we were sort of
drawing a red line we believe that there
might be another chemical gas attack a
chemical attack coming up and then the
Pentagon said we've got no clue what the
Trump White House is talking about and
there's sort of two main possibilities
one is not to use the term false flag
but it's possible that in order to
rattle Sabres the White House is just
sort of making up that they've observed
the possibility that Syria is gearing up
for a chemical attack and you could
argue it to take attention away from oh
I don't know pick whichever one of the
top ten Trump scandals you want and that
it would be a reason to do a way to that
possibility number two is that it's true
that the White House was briefed by
intelligence agencies about that but
that it was classified and not supposed
to be shared and after the White House
went public with it
you've got the Pentagon and others
saying we don't know what they're
talking about because they are they're
spilling secret information which would
not be the first time so we we may
eventually find out
we may never find out obviously there's
so many disasters going on right now
that it that we could imagine why the
Donald Trump White House would want to
distract but I think you're you don't
need to go to false flag hypotheses to
be skeptical about the underlying
reality of the situation you know what I
mean chase yeah no I totally get that I
don't mean to prod that kinda quit like
that word that was just kind of what
came to mind there but yeah no I totally
get what you're saying it's just you
know it's some very you know sketchy
territory I guess and I just it's pretty
hard to trust what's coming out of our
military especially with us using stuff
like wife's white phosphorus and
depleted uranium so it's just very
hypocritical yeah completed uranium I
know less about white phosphorus yes
used in Mosul though arguably the United
States claims that the international law
not to get into white phosphorus and
international law but and by the way
international law for warfare like the
concept of it is interesting to begin
with but you're allowed to use white
phosphorus as a sort of shielding
mechanism to allow the ingress or egress
of troops or victims but you're not
allowed to use white phosphorus as a
primary means of attack of course it's
not as easy to control as one might
imagine and how was the u.s. use did the
US is use in Mosul and and in Syria I
believe is well fall within that or
outside of that big questions here chase
not ones we're going to get an answer to
today but I do thank you for the call
really really appreciate it
we are going to take a break we will
take more calls after the break in the
meantime you can give us a like at
facebook.com slash David Pakman show